[経典唱え][仏教の経典]
あれはティマーニバリッサンティ マヤ メッタナティマーニ バリッサ マティ サレーコカラニヨ パレ ブッダジャ
バリッサンティ マヤ メッタ スッバジャ バリッサ マティ サレーコカラニヨ パレ パパッピッタ バリ
ッサンティ マヤ メッタ カルヤナミッタ バリッサ マティ サレーコカラニヨ パレ パマッタ バリッサンティ マ
ヤ メッタ アッパマッタ バリッサ マティ サレーコカラニヨ パレア サッダ バリッサンティ マヤ メッタ
サッダ バリッサ マティ サレーコカラニヨ パレア ヒリッタ バリッサンティ マヤ メッタ ヒリマナ バリッサ
マティ サレーコカラニヨ パレア ムッタアピー バリッサンティ マヤ メッタ オッパピー バリッサ マティ サレーコカ
ラニヨ パレアッパ スッタ バリッサンティ マヤ メッタ バフッスッタ バリッサ マティ サレーコカラニヨ パレ
プシッタ バリッサンティ マヤ メッタ アラッダウィーヤ バリッサ マティ サレーコカラニヨ パレ ムッタサティ
バリッサンティ マヤ メッタ ウパッティタサティ バリッサ マティ サレーコカラニヨ パレ ドゥッパニャ バリ
ッサンティ マヤ メッタ パニャサンパンナ バリッサ マティ サレーコカラニヨ パレ サングイッティ
パラマシ アダナラ ヒドゥンパティ ニッサンギ バリッサンティ マヤ メッタ アサンギッティ パラマシ アマダナラ
ヒスッパティ ニッサンギ バリッサ マティ サレーコカラニヨ
Sādhu Sādhu Sādhu
それだけでかなりの祝福にもなります
それで道徳の項目はちゃんと四十四あります
それでかなり立派な道徳の項目なんです
お勉強してほしいところでございます
で 日本語で一人で読むときは日本語で読んでも構いません
例えば二十四番目の項目を見てください
他人は怒るが 我々は怒らないようにと戒めましょう
そういう風にもちょっとちょっと役に立つ
日常の生活でね  これは結構役に立ちますけどね
それからもう二十六だったらね
他人は他者の徳を軽視するが
我々は軽視しないように戒めましょうとかね
それ二十六番目 これわかりやすいところ
それで二十八番目 他人は嫉妬するが
我々は嫉妬しないようにと戒めましょう
試しに二 三週間ぐらい日本語で読み上げてください
人格はどうなるのかと
いかにブッダの教えが力強く
人が人を変えるのかと
お分かりになると思います
で またわかりやすい行といえば
すぐ役に立つというのはそこら辺でしょうね
二十五番目も同じですね
他人は恨むが 我々は恨まないようにと戒めましょうと
それから三十四番目 他人は反抗的であるが
我々はこれ何でしたっけ？素直に？素直になるようにと戒めましょう
で 三十六番目 他人は怠るが
我々は怠らないようにと戒めましょう
それで 一番最後に一番強烈なあの不道徳と道徳になっているのは四十四番目なんですね
このものすごくいろんな意見にしがみつくこと
他人は自分の主権に取り憑かれ
しがみつき 捨てられないようでいるが
我々は自分の主観に囚われず
しがみつくことなく 簡単に捨てられるように戒めましょう
ということで 大変力強い経典でございます
どうかあの日本語でもよろしいですので
たまたま読み上げてみてください
今日であの経典の文は終了して終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
Sādhu Sādhu Sādhu